how did it feel to get dressed up for
your first ever
unreal show unreal magical um
i don't do this every day what what was
the process like
for you today so this morning i paced
around my apartment a lot um
probably annoyed my friend and then glam
came
and they are just so amazing and i
feel like a princess a little bit just
like a little bit so
yeah you look fantastic i can't help but
notice all the bling on you
like your earrings your rings can you
walk me through what's
what's happening this is i mean these
are just these are real
diamonds and i mean because of course
they would be right but i can't believe
they trusted me to wear this so that's
all is there a security guard following
you around here
there should be there shouldn't be do
you know how many carrots those are
uh five i think and these at least is
that a lot it seems like a lot i think
that's a lot of carrots i think it's a
lot of carrots but
more carrots than i consume in a regular
day so same
probably combined well i love that
they're real they look fantastic
let's talk about the success of the show
i mean
do you have celebrity fans that are
sliding into the dms telling you
how obsessed they are with the show yet
yeah um it's been a pretty overwhelming
to to just to know that some of the
people that you admire have seen the
show
um and like the show yeah so it's really
like i know okay so like i know like
maybe just like haley bieber has
seen her show and that just like makes
me sweat it makes me sweat a little bit
but it's very exciting and um the
support has been really fantastic
did you grow up a fan of justin bieber
that's amazing what's in store for
season two do we know it's a roller
coaster
it could be i even i don't know the full
details
but i am on the edge of my seat i know
it's going to be
a full package of just excitement and
plot and
craziness and so i'm i'm really excited
tonight scarlett johansson is being
honored
why do you think she's an icon of our
generation
oh she's just like she's timeless isn't
she she really is she's so elegant
i know just everything she does it's
just with such poise and grace and she's
so articulate and and just
a fantastic talented actress and i look
up to her a lot so
i think it's well deserved yeah me too
thank you so much congratulations on
everything nice to see you
thank you